welcome to rt.com i'm chris sweeney and
today i'm joined by brian tingley who is
a licensed marriage and family therapist
based on washington state in the u.s and
also his attorney matt sharp who's
senior counsel at the alliance uh for
defending freedom also in america so
great to be joining you both thank you
for coming on online today
thanks for having us
thank you for the opportunity
it's quite a controversial case um brian
was in court um and essentially he was
um
challenging a course decision to not him
allowed to
provide
sexual um orientation change therapy for
minors which maybe some people might
informally call conversion therapy um
i think brian was arguing that and his
legal team were arguing it was against
his first amendment rights under free
speech um obviously the court disagreed
um so maybe either of you could maybe
explain this at a legal position and you
know what the case was about and what
you were arguing
well um
chris um
i've been a counselor for
over 20 years and until recently
the government never told me what i
could say or not say in my sessions and
this law
violates freedom of speech in a very
private setting which is my counseling
office and the government does not
belong in a counselor's office and so we
are challenging this law that the state
of washington
is censoring speech that it disagrees
with and so we're challenging that
so essentially um it's been it's over
the content of what you're saying or is
it just that you don't want any rules
within the you know the counseling room
for essentially i mean because obviously
you have to tell the government what's
going on that concern or what services
you're offering because i i assume
they're not listening so you know you
know where does this sort of
freedom of speech act and
you know your content sort of change if
you know what i mean you know where's
the defining line there
so um my counseling involves nothing but
talking with my clients and
um
my client my miners
specifically come in in a lot of pain
and they want a safe place to talk about
things they feel like they cannot talk
about anywhere else
and there's no scientific evidence that
um voluntary conversational counseling
on these type of on these subjects like
sexuality and gender uh creating your
risk of harm
and when the government censors speech
um it stops the process and the help
these clients want to have these
conversations and so when the government
uh censors these conversations i have it
robs my clients that's when they lose
hope uh or potentially lose hope that
they can live the lives that they want
or achieve the goals that they want to
achieve i'm only trying to help clients
achieve the goals they set for
themselves yeah and because
to add to that a little bit to your
question about the content that that is
part of one of the issues with this law
so the washington law says counselors
can affirm their clients choices as it
relates to their sexual orientation or
their gender identity but what the
counselors can't do is that if a client
comes in and wants to live consistent
with their biological sex or wants to uh
sort of overcome same-sex attractions
you can't talk about that so in other
words the government is picking and
choosing certain conversations and for
certain viewpoints that it says are okay
and then others that it's trying to
prohibit and that's one thing that our
constitution says you can't do you can't
favor certain viewpoints you can't favor
certain ideas over others the government
has to be neutral and that's what the
government is doing here is is putting
itself in the conversations between
brian and his counselors and saying you
can say this but you can't say that
and i think so i mean i think something
important to clear up is maybe some of
the
the stereotyping on this issue is that
you know you're you're imposing us on
people but people are coming to brine
they're sitting down they're saying
i've got an issue with being gay
please can you help me is that is that
consistent or am i making that too basic
well i'm i'm
i i do all kinds of things i see
children adults couples i see families i
work on a variety of issues like anxiety
depression
marital conflict
parenting
same-sex attraction struggles um
gender identity struggle so i see a wide
variety of things
it's just that the government is now
saying that my clients can have certain
goals or not have certain goals and
that's very unusual um
this law uh
tries to stop uh my clients from
setting goals for themselves and
achieving the goals they want and it
could i could be fine just for having
these conversations with these clients
and in terms of across america is this a
uniform thing or is washington state
particularly um sort of cracking down on
this or or is this a uniform situation
across all of the united states
no in fact there's a few other states
that have done this but recently there's
been some court rulings uh there was one
just a few months ago uh dealing with a
law in florida
that was almost identical to what uh
washington was trying to do a city in
florida had passed it and the court of
appeals struck it down and said this
violates the right to free speech the
government can't insert itself into
these counseling conversations so what
we're
hopefully trying to do with with this
case with brian's case is take that
decision in florida that applies to
florida and georgia and another state
and use it to go after these laws in
washington state and also have them
declared unconstitutional as violating
that right to free speech
so i mean essentially it comes down to
what goes on in the counselor's room
should be completely free of the
government and brian should be able to
talk to his clients
in complete privilege about what they
want to talk about and offer his
expertise the government should not get
involved
like i'd like to uh
say that uh counselors there's all kinds
of laws and ethics that um
do not allow me to just do anything that
i want to do and so i follow the laws
the ex the ethics as well as the my
professional training
um what this law does is it wants me to
censor my forced me to censor my own
speech and to counsel my clients on the
premise that same-sex attraction or one
achieving comfort with their biological
sex cannot be achieved and is harmful
um and this goes against my my own
conviction my own convictions my
experience it goes against my clients
experience and it goes against the
scientific research
i mean some people may say you know this
is sort of
going against homosexuality is
demonizing it it's making it seem a bad
thing you know how would you respond to
that sort of criticism
well you know the state of washington
has always had room for different
communities to live according to their
own beliefs and the state of washington
doesn't get to decide what uh people get
to believe or what lifestyles it should
have or that they should abandon the
lifestyles that they have
so um
this is about uh people being able to uh
have goals for their own lives not the
government and to seek the help that
they want and not have the government uh
intervene in that and the courts have
consistently um
kept the government from um prying into
conversations between professionals
and the uh or between individuals and
the professionals that they seek help
from and so
we're only wanting that freedom uh for
myself and for my clients
and as it stands i mean if you were in a
consultation with a client and they said
brian i've got an issue with you know
same-sex attraction can you help me
as of today what would you have to do
and what would be the process
i i'm not sure i understand the question
could you repeat that chris yeah if
you're on a consultation today and a
client just have to say brian um i've
been thinking about it i've got an issue
with same-sex attraction can you help me
would you have to say no we've got to
stop this conversation right now is that
how it stands legally you know what
would be the process
well the i treat all clients exactly the
same they come in i listen to them i
hear the struggles that they have maybe
anxiety depression could be conflict uh
within attractions um
a conflict with relationships a whole
wide variety of issues so i use my
expertise to help them with that um i
don't i don't treat anybody any
different
if the goals they have is to
explore uh
conflicting sexual desires
i help them sort through that i help
them understand their thoughts their
feelings
and it's those conversations that they
learn about themselves
and to add to that i think one of the
reasons we filed this lawsuit is brian
and his client shouldn't have to live in
fear that the government's going to come
knocking on his door saying what were
you just saying to that client what what
goals were you helping them to achieve
that they chose
that's why we filed this legal action is
to have a clear ruling on brian's behalf
that he doesn't have to live in fear his
clients don't have to live in fear of
the government showing up and censoring
their conversations
i mean maybe this is one more for you
matt then in that sense i mean if brian
was just to continue having his
his therapy sessions counseling with the
people and they never told anyone you
know could it just continue is it only
if someone hears about it you know
because i guess what goes on that room
is confidential
well i think one of the things and and
even the court recognized this is that
when we have laws that violate free
speech we shouldn't have to sit back and
wait and hope and pray that the
government doesn't come knocking on our
door when laws violate our right to free
speech we've got a right to challenge
them we've got a right to get a clear
ruling that the government can't enforce
that against people like brian and the
clients he serves and so that's what all
we're asking for here is a clear ruling
that brian and his clients have the
freedom to have these conversations and
not live in fear of the government
knocking on their door one day
and where do we stand legally right now
i mean i know that i know those are
ruling so are you appealing that ruling
and you know what is this a legal
position as we speak
so we had filed a request to to have
this law enjoined to have the court
ruling that the government can't enforce
it against brian uh the first level the
district court did rule against us on
that and so now we're exploring uh the
option of an appeal to the next level up
uh to the court of appeals to to get
relief for ryan and to get that lower
court ruling overturned
and and for you brian i mean if you i
mean obviously you can't talk about
patience i wouldn't expect you to but
you know are you worried about your
patients if you have to stop providing
certain services because maybe they've
come to depend on you and you're
offering them help if that helps removed
are you worried about their welfare
there's no question um that when people
like myself are censored it's the
clients that lose they lose the hope
that they might have to live the life
that they want they
feel that maybe they can't achieve the
goals that they want to achieve for
themselves
and um and this law intimidates people
um i have people come from time to time
and they uh they're afraid to talk about
these things and
the counseling office is supposed to be
the safe place talk about things that
they can't talk about anywhere else and
when the government's
trying to impose themselves into the
counseling office
it's my clients that lose
and does this um ruling apply
universally across minors and adults or
i know your case was just maybe focused
more on minors but is this is this a
blanket thing or are we just talking
about minors in this sense
in the state of washington this law is
directed towards minors yes
and if they were come to you you know
would they come usually with their
parents consent or are minors allowed to
come to you completely depend on the
parents so just for people's maybe um
you know are not familiar with the law
can can children just book an
appointment and show up at your office
um well in the state of washington at 13
you can sign for your own um services in
healthcare um it's not uncommon for
people to come minors at the prompting
of their parents but i only work with
them if they
want to work with me voluntarily and
participate voluntarily so i only work
with them
in the goals that they want to set for
themselves i mean i think one thing you
you both mentioned briefly to start with
me but we're talking about you know the
trans thing and maybe people changing
gender or sexuality and that seems to be
promoted but this is not and i think
that's where you're particularly mad
seeing there is a a difference in the
law and imbalance
yeah it's exactly right is that when
you've got the state of washington
saying if someone comes in and they say
i i want to begin a living as the
opposite sex the opposite gender then
the state of washington says yes brian
you can do that with an individual you
can help them achieve that goal but then
if that another person walks in and says
no i actually want to live consistent
with my biological sex can you help me
with that well then according to the
state of washington brian has to slam
the door and say no i can't help you
with that i can't help you achieve that
goal and so that that difference that
that this viewpoint sort of path a is
allowed if you want to affirm your
gender identity but path b if you want
to
live and affirm your biological sex
that's not allowed that's where the
courts have been very
uh very restrictive on governments and
laws trying to do that because they
recognize if the government gets to pick
and choose then that gives the
government a lot of authority over our
free speech and over those conversations
that's why the government does not get
to pick the client's goals and what the
conversations go toward that's between
brian and his clients for the client to
decide what the goal is and then brian
to walk with them on that path towards
achieving that goal
and brian i mean if if clients can't
explore these goals with you and another
another therapist what do you think
we're going to see in this a public
joint we're going to see you know heaven
forbid suicides or people hurting
themselves or issues do you do you think
we're going to see things like that if
if they can't access help from people
like yourself
part of the process of
people getting help is a safe place for
them to discover themselves and they
need that safety to talk they need that
safety to express themselves they need
uh safety to uh for a counselor like
myself to respond to them in a way and
show them that that's okay
when there's a law like this that
threatens to take my
license away in my livelihood
um there's these extra um barriers uh
these censorship barriers that interrupt
that process and again it's the client
that's that's losing and
um
yeah i would uh say that they would not
be getting the quality of service that
they uh should be getting and there's uh
certainly
um unfortunately some possibly some not
good outcomes from that
and what happens right now i mean uh
maybe also mark can maybe chip on this a
bit is right now if if if a client says
to you i want to discuss this right now
i'm a minor i want to discuss you know
changing my uh you know gender
orientation
um
or preference you know what do you do in
that sense do you have to say no the
court said i can't do it you'll have to
leave
i think
go ahead brian
go ahead as you say as of as if things
stand right now um you know the concern
is and and the washington state uh
washington district court recognized
this that nothing right now stops the
government from coming in and fining
brian if he has that conversation so
he's he's got to weigh all of that out
and that's why we are looking at the
possibility of appeal because we don't
want him to have to turn away a client
we don't want that individual to be
denied the counseling that they're
seeking because as you were just
discussing that can have serious
implications for an individual that's
seeking that and being denied that yeah
and so just going forward brian you know
you know where did you go from here are
you just committed to keep on fighting
your case and providing the best health
to your clients is that you know is that
how you see it forward because i think
there's a lot of toxicity around this
and i don't think anyone wants to see it
get into kind of hate speech and people
arguing and criticize each other
particularly social media i guess you
want to focus on your clients
i'm against anything that's abusive or
coercive um most of the presentation of
the law and what it uh what they present
it uh to do i agree with the actual
wording of the law and how it actually
uh when i researched it and i thought
hey i'm a therapist i know i'm a
counselor i know how this works um it
was censorship and um so
yeah my concern is for my clients and
i'm going to continue
um to help my clients the best that i
can follow
the laws and do what i'm supposed to do
but i am if this law stands it's the
clients that are going to suffer and um
so we're going to challenge it we
believe that the laws are on our side
and so we're hopeful
yeah
well thank you very much uh both for
joining me today i do appreciate your
you know it's obviously a very kind of
controversial but interesting subject
and i thank you both for joining me so
thank you brian thank you matt
thank you chris thanks chris